what are stakes and sacrifice and how do
they work together
oh that's a good question um so so
commonly we think about stakes in your
story as
the consequence or the thing that will
happen if your character fails to
achieve
their goal right so um like we were
talking about in bridesmaids
if uh kristen wiig fails at being her
best friend's maid of honor then her
friendship
is her friendship will probably fail or
you know her friendship's at stake so
there her friendship will take a hit
right um she may lose her best friend so
that's what's at stake is her friendship
with
uh lillian um sacrifice
is it's this is you know this is sort of
a story nerd distinction to look at
because you can kind of lump all of
these things together
but sacrifice is what your character
um is sort of the cost of participation
of your character
taking on this goal or this task that
they're trying to do
right so the the cost of participation
tells us um how important a goal is to
someone
if they're really willing to sacrifice a
lot in order to pursue this thing right
so
bridesmaids isn't a great example but
just say that in order to
go for the olympic gold i have to give
up my family
my girlfriend my job all this stuff
those are all
cost of participation things those are
all sacrifices that i'm making
in order to pursue this goal what's at
stake if i
don't win the gold is perhaps my olympic
gymnastics career right so those are two
different things so my career's at stake
that is hanging in the balance but the
sacrifices that i'm making
are separate from that however the
sacrifices can help me see how important
this goal is to this character because
i'm willing to sacrifice all that stuff
in pursuit of it
the challenge with sacrifice is making
sure that the sacrifice isn't
so big and unwarranted that the audience
then thinks your character's stupid
right because if they're giving up all
this stuff and it feels like
but they're giving up all this stuff for
what for this goal that you know to
to enter the the town race to win a a
new griddle or something like that
doesn't seem like it's worth giving up
all this stuff so your audience won't
get on board with your character
pursuing a goal that doesn't seem
to warrant all the sacrifice that
they're making an example that i always
use is the ring so the ring is about a
woman who um
who watches a cursed videotape and then
she has seven days
to solve the mystery of this curse in
order to stop
it and save her life right so what's at
stake
in that pursuit is her life we know that
her life is hanging in the balance if
she fails at achieving that goal
she's going to die um the sacrifices
that she makes
in pursuit of that goal include um
spending less time with her son so we
know that this
saving her life is very important to her
not only to save her life right
life and death but also because she
doesn't she's a single mom and she
doesn't want to leave her son
an orphan right but so she's sacrificing
time with him
time that could make her feel like a
good mom
attentive mom but she has to make that
sacrifice in order to pursue the goal
because the goal is so important to her
because the stakes are so big does that
kind of make sense it does okay okay
what do you think 99 of screenwriters
get wrong with their screenplays
one of the biggest things that i see as
issues in scripts that i read right so i
don't know if it's 99
of screenwriters get this wrong but i
will say it is very common
is um not building the stakes properly
so that the audience is
invested so so you know it could be
an exciting story but we'll only go
along
so long with you know somebody trying to
do something
if we don't understand why they're doing
it or what it means to them
right so um building the stakes of
showing us you know
what not only what happens if they fail
to achieve this goal
but also why does that matter why is it
so important to them
um what does that mean to them
internally sort of all of
those questions are really what get us
emotionally
invested right so if we look at the
movie bridesmaids again
um the you know her goal is to be your
best friend's maid of honor
what's at stake is externally is her
friendship we know that her
the friendship is kind of the last good
thing she has in her life and
um if she fails at being her best
friends
if she fails at pulling off this sort of
like made of honor duty for her best
friend
on her most important day right that
their friendship is going to suffer so
that's what's at stake for her
however there's also a deeper internal
thing that that means
for the protagonist she her friendship
being the last
best or sorry the last good thing that
she has in her life speaks to her
self-worth
she has essentially failed in all other
aspects of her life
if she fails at this she will have
proven
she's not a good enough friend she can't
keep up with where her friend is sort of
going in her life right like her friend
is kind of moving into this
rich people's world and adult world
she's getting married she's going to
have a real
like you know house and husband and all
this stuff
so it's it all of that kind of speaks to
how annie the kristen wiig character
feels about herself
if she fails at doing this it will say
something about her
as a person so that you know
setting up those like or helping the
under the audience understand
the deeper meaning behind the stakes
it's great to have
external concrete stakes that we can see
because we're watching movies right but
helping the audience understand what it
really means
and why that meaning is so important to
the character i would say
that's one of the biggest things that
people miss when they're writing scripts
so you think maybe a lot of people might
have a clear goal
for their character and and that we see
that this character
wants it at all costs but we're not
seeing the little
sub things in their lives that will
suffer yeah
if they don't get it and all the things
they have to sacrifice or do
or compromise yeah i think it's it's um
a lot of people understand that they
need stakes in their story
there you know there needs to be some
consequence for failure right
otherwise why is this character doing
this thing um
but i think the thing that a lot of
people miss
is is tying those stakes to
a deeper meaning so it's not just an
external thing it's not just because
when you're dealing with things that
aren't life and death it's
it's even more important to go into the
the the why behind it right that letting
us know
why does this and why does it matter who
cares if this character
fails at being a maid of honor who cares
right
that those external stakes we get them
and we see them
but they only get us emotionally
invested because we understand what they
mean
to the protagonist so that's the part
you know and that's the hard thing
to do which is probably why it's missed
a lot so
right i'm thinking of let's say lady
bird you talked about that so
if the main character she grew up i
think in sacramento
and but she felt like she grew up on the
wrong side of the tracks where all her
friends
maybe were a little more affluent and
she's always wanted to kind of prove
that she belonged in that world kind of
thing yeah and so
even though she has this like loving
family at home yeah it's
to her she just wants to be accepted in
the friendship world
so i think if i remember right her her
goal in that movie
like the the actual sort of external
goal that we're kind of like hanging the
you know the plot on like the structure
of the movie
i think it was getting accepted into an
east coast school was that right
right and then the mom's like you're
just going to go to community college
yeah
right and so so if we just say that's
your goal and i can't remember for sure
if this is exactly the way the movie was
structured but if we say that's her goal
is like she's
she's pursuing getting accepted to an
east coast school if she
fails at getting accepted to an east
coast school she's gonna have to go to
sacramento state and prove her mom right
right so that's kind of the external
stakes but what does that mean to her
internally i would say
it would to her going off of what you
said it would
prove that she isn't as good as those
kids that she wants to fit in with or
maybe that she'll never be
anything more than you know the
surroundings that she
grew up in right which for most of the
movies she sees as not good enough
i think by the end she comes around to
sort of appreciating the upbringing she
had and
where she came from right but um but for
most of the movie
she feels like this is very this is a
very important goal to her because she's
trying to
leave this behind and if she can't do
that it will basically prove that she
fits in here at this place that she
doesn't think is good enough you know
right
right okay yeah and i think actually
that's what a lot of people related to
because it's that internal feeling of
like
i think a lot of people can relate to
that like wanting to wanting to sort of
get out of the town that you were raised
in
right and then maybe maybe relating even
to the eventual feeling of like oh it
wasn't so bad i actually kind of
appreciate that
right or or growing up in a town where
there's like
a divide in
access to different things and and
wanting to go with the kids that
the cool kids that seemed like they had
everything and they had the big house
and
and her feeling like she was less than
because her parents even though
hard-working or i know the dad was out
of work for a while but
you know especially the mom you know was
was a nurse or whatever and
feeling like what wasn't glamorous
enough yeah and she wanted to be a new
yeah she wanted to be this other person
right and
um i think failing at that goal kind of
kind of what was internally at stake for
her was proving that she
couldn't be that other person she
couldn't be more than
i guess she was born into you know right
okay
you